very honored here in st. Louis to have
Harry Benson who's taking some
photographs of the players he's a
legendary photographer he photographed
the Beatles he photographed every
president since Eisenhower and he's with
Grand Master Maurice Ashley now to chat
about all that and the upcoming show
kings and queens it's opening in October
at the world chess Hall of Fame Wow
and in addition to photographing all
those illustrious names as you mentioned
he also famously photographed
Bobby Fischer took up a great
relationship with Bobby and we're
working for Life magazine at the time
Harry thank you so much for joining us
we know you're a legend of photography
you must be enjoying yourself here at
the sink field come may be a legend but
not upstairs what was it like what was
it like to be as beckoning to your
photographer what was it like to be a
photographer for Bobby Fischer no wasn't
for him I was for Life magazine and I
got on I met Bobby now gin keno and the
reason I gone with them was I knew
nothing about chess why did that help
help because he wanted to hear about the
New York Jets wanted to hear about
Muhammad Ali because I covered his face
he was interested in sport because
anyone who spoke chess when Bobby
thought there were more on his level
right what did you keep yeah kill ya boo
okay you know I
Bobby signature Wow let me grab that so
I can show it was a difficult thing to
have sure wasn't kids somebody and kids
people had no check
took his money or something with some
paranoid reason you know Wow
now we see you there signing the book
why looking dapper and taking
photographs was it like jumping the
generations to be taking photographs of
these this generation of players well
they look like a bunch of rock stars the
cut the trouble with and Bobby we speak
about it once he hated the old guys you
know in the new year in the New York
Chess Club there were a bunch of old
guys I mean really old man and Bobby
like we're seeing a picture of your your
chair being reserved because it was so
crowded upstairs so you three you
certainly are well appreciated because
I'm so old that was fine Bobby
oh no show that picture I can't believe
lots of bobby fisher' photos as you flip
through the the book there yeah picture
I want to show you because I like it
this Bobby
the thing about a still photograph that
will never happen again
yes that's a glimpsing gone forever
Bobby will never be kissed by a horse
actually but Bobby had met a girl who
really been much better how's it
different photographing him and
photographing anyone else oh no he was
yeah he was tricky he was he was
difficult I mean you had to we had to
bring
a lot of pictures of the New York Jets
together think I'm going to do things
very difficult but it was a good guy
would call me at 3:00 in the morning I
need to talk about nuclear disarmament
really nice it becomes you know you were
taking those phone calls at 3:00 in the
morning in the morning from California
Wow
and that what happened you know what
happened two or three times a month
really interesting and and you've been
photographing now our players like
Caruana
and and magnus carlsen what I'm good
what's what's this I assume you're
referring to both of them are
good-looking wasn't I good looking but
counsin is it looks like movies dresses
well you know it's an interesting
looking man and you enjoy capturing this
generation of players as I mentioned
yeah I need more though I need actually
Vanity Fair want me to to do a piece on
it give some photographs tell me about
your exhibit that's gonna be opening
it's gonna be your second exhibition at
the world chess Hall of Fame tell me
about that it's really about kings and
queens of people of photographs through
the year but we did my wife is handling
it so in these things she'd be better
off talking to the dog leave it up to my
wife better between Kings like king of
Jordan or Don King well I'm sure it's
going to be Spectre is going to be
special because you have such a
wonderful eye and cat
sure those emotional moments and we will
expect everyone to first of all get get
this book I want to make sure everybody
has the book about Bobby Fischer the
great photographs in here and if you
ever get to to st. Louis come to the
world chess all of Fame has it has been
a pleasure to talk to you thanks so much
for joining us in deep of the great work
yeah thank you very much a pleasure
thank you